ce
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
seraient les bienvenues sur france 24 à
la une ce soir l'ouverture d'une enquête
par la justice guinéenne pour déterminer
les causes de la mort du jeune homme tué
par balles la semaine dernière un décès
lors d'affrontements entre
protestataires et forces de l'ordre en
marge d'une manifestation contre la
hausse des prix du carburant du
carburant nous serons à conakry dans ce
journal six responsables de l'opposition
tchadien condamné à un an de prison avec
sursis pour trouble à l'ordre public
qu'ils avaient été poursuivis après une
manifestation contre la france qui avait
dégénéré leur avocat dénonce un procès
expéditif nous serons à n'djamena dans
un instant et puis ce soir nous recevons
el malick ndiaye porte-parole du pcf
parti de l'opposant sénégalais ousmane
son co ayez oui askanwi la liste de sa
coalition pour les législatives de
juillet a été invalidée par le conseil
constitutionnel
interview dans ce journal
la justice guinéenne a ouvert une
enquête pour déterminer les causes de la
mort du jeune homme tué par balle
mercredi en marge d'une manifestation
contre la hausse du prix du carburant à
conakry une marche prévue ce lundi en
hommage à la victime à l'appel du front
national pour la défense de la
constitution a été reportée les
explications de notre correspondant à
conakry malik diakité
ce lundi matin en devant la presse le
procureur général de conakry alfonso ch
alors wait a publié l'autopsié de
thierno mamadou diallo selon ce rapport
le jeune guinéen est décédé je cite
suite à un traumatisme d'origine
balistique tiré dans une position génie
flexible probable le procureur général a
aussi indiqué que des témoins de
l'assassinât de ce jeune de 19 ans ont
déjà été identifiées il a par ailleurs
mis en garde contre je cite toute
récupération politique de ses
funérailles il ya dessus la famille
de la victime ils ont été claires par
rapport à leur position
et le veulent que
soit faite l'on ne peut pas
en lieu et place de la famille
procéder à une récupération politique ou
sociale de quoi que ce soit
c'est une procédure judiciaire qui est
ouverte
cette procédure judiciaire n'a pas
besoin de tomic elle a besoin que de la
sérénité ternois mamadou diallo un élève
de 19 ans pourrait être le premier mort
enregistré lors des mouvements de
contestation depuis l'arrivée des
militaires au pouvoir
le vice président nigérian s'est rendu
sur les lieux du drame survenu dimanche
des hommes armés ont attaqué une église
catholique en pleine messe au -
vingt-et-une personnes ont été tuées et
une quarantaine de blessés dont des
enfants ce massacre perpétré dans le sud
ouest du nigeria a suscité l'effroi dans
le pays
au tchad six responsables de
l'opposition ont été condamnés à un an
de prison avec sursis pour entre autres
troubles à l'ordre public ils avaient
été poursuivis après une manifestation
émaillée d'incidents le 14 mai dernier
contre la france leurs avocats qui ont
boycotté le procès dénonce une justice
expéditive malgré une condamnations
inférieures aux réquisitions
les précisions de notre correspondant à
n'djamena mamadou dit mbaye le juge les
reconnaît coupable du saccage des
stations-service du groupe total une
source locale nous rapporte que dans la
salle où les parents des condamnés
étaient venus en nombre c'était un grand
ouf de soulagement à la longe du verdict
selon leurs avocats ils vont faire appel
pour demander la relaxe simple et sa
team a simplement de désolation c'est un
procès de la honte
et c'est même
un attentat à la liberté d'expression à
la liberté d'opinion aux droits
fondamentaux à la liberté de marche et
tous les six condamnés ont pris part le
14 mai dernier à une marche contre la
politique française au chat la france
qu'ils accusent de soutenir le régime en
place la marche autorisée par les
autorités avaient débordé occasionnant
des scènes des casses et de vandalisme
sur des intérêts économiques français
cette condamnation en algérie said
bouteflika le frère cadet de l'ex
président abdelaziz bouteflika déjà en
détention pour des poursuites dans
d'autres affaires a été condamné ce
lundi à huit ans de prison ferme pour
des faits de corruption son co accusé
l'ancien patron des patrons à l'ead aide
également condamné dans plusieurs
affaires à lui écopé de 4 ans de prison
ferme
en tunisie les magistrats ont entamé une
grève d'une semaine renouvelable une
grève visiblement suivi observée à
l'appel des principaux syndicats
professionnels des magistrats pour
protester contre le limogeage jeudi par
le président queille cède 57 jugent
accusé entre autres de corruption et
entrave à la justice
on part à présent au sénégal ou le rejet
de la liste des titulaires de la
coalition d'opposition au yémen où ils
sèment le trouble à moins de deux mois
des élections législatives le conseil
constitutionnel a également a invalidé
la liste des suppléants de la majorité
présidentielle des no box yaakaar ce
soir nous donnons la parole el malick
ndiaye secrétaire national de la
communication du pasteur le parti de
l'opposant ousman sonko bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous bonsoir merci pour
l'invitation alors on va on va d'abord
parlé de l'actualité votre liste a été
invalidée elle a été considérée comme
pour non conformité en fait quelle est
votre réaction à cette invalidation du
conseil constitutionnel une réaction de
désolation nous notons qu'au sénégal
aujourd'hui on nous a sorti un nouveau
type de doigts qui cherchait à écarter
merveille le la coalition de
l'opposition
on ne peut dire même la majorité de
l'opposition la coalition --à lui qui
aujourd'hui a raflé pas mal de villes
lors des élections locales et on se rend
compte qu'ils veulent éliminer afin
qu'ils ne participent pas aux
législatives prochaines ce qui est
désolant c'est de noter que l'actuel
président utilise la justice et son
administration pour tripatouiller pour
manipuler les lois la constitution et
tous afin d'éliminer pratiquement c'est
du farouche opposant à savoir présence
dans son corps khalifa sall entre autres
qu'est-ce qui se passe
voilà un verdict qui sort qu'il nous
dise pour une première fois dans le
monde entier nous allons aller à des
élections avec une liste
qui est qui a été subdivisée en deux les
titulaires par là et les suppléants
il y avait à ce cas lui va partir avec
une liste de super sans tête de liste
sans image de la tête de liste et une
liste incomplète parce que la liste
titulaire normalement doit être à 53
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
liste de se plaire de 50 ce qui est
inacceptable
ce qui est inédit même dans l'histoire
politique du sénégal alors pardonnez moi
je vais faire l'avocat du diable si vous
dites que les autorités sénégalaises
cherche des moyens légaux c'est ce que
vous dites pour vous éliminer pour avoir
pourquoi avoir commis une erreur aussi
flagrante
c'est cette erreur qui a qui a causé
votre invalides va être à validité
l'arrivée hâtive de votre liste est une
erreur assez grossière beaucoup
d'observateurs ne comprennent pas et
vous l'avez reconnue vous même
d'ailleurs mais parce que c'est normal
parce que depuis son accession au
pouvoir le président macky sall cherche
à trouver tout le temps des comme vous
le savez pourquoi vous avez pas fait en
sorte qu'il n'y ait pas ce genre
d'erreurs visiblement c'est là une
candidate qui était à la fois candidate
et suppose il invalide s'il n'y a pas
une probabilité d'erreur on aménage pas
pratiquement des solutions c'est-à-dire
pour les corriger la loi l'a prévue
c'est normal qu'il y ait des erreurs
parce que tout simplement ils ont rendu
très complexe le processus électoral
avec le parrainage qui a été rejetée
d'abord par la coudée cedeao ils ont
enlevé durant les locales sachant que
c'est quasi impossible de de
l'impôt pratiquement de l'appliquer
aujourd'hui ils ont ramené ça et si on
se base sur les textes normalement la
coalition au pouvoir ne devait pas
participer aux élections parce que tout
simplement ils ont un supplice de
parrainage qui est complètement banni
par la loi actuelle mais ils ont voulu
faire du forcing le présent chaque salle
c'est qu'il a voulu se faire de sorte
que la liste de benno bloqué à 4 passes
parce que d'abord il on est un supplice
de parrainage donc on devait invalider
ces motif d'irrecevabilité
ensuite l'autre problème c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas respecté la parité maintenant
pour faire ça d'ailleurs que leur liste
des suppléants était invalide c'est
inédit est est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec moi qu'on peut pas aller à des
élections avec des listes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui une liste des titulaires
et une liste de super c'est pas possible
ils ont ils ont ils ont aujourd'hui tous
les juristes du sénégal tous les
constitutionnalistes sont tombés
d'accord sur une seule et unique chose
ils ont encore dit tout sauf le doigt ce
qui est triste aujourd'hui au 21ème
siècle dans un sénégal où on voit depuis
des décennies qu'on se retrouve avec un
président qui fait tout pour écarter ses
farouches opposants alors autre point
que j'aimerais souligner certains
certaines sources évoquent des tensions
au sein même de votre coalition des
tensions qui serait selon eux à
l'origine de cette erreur
certains parlent de sabotage interne est
ce que vous confient rien à voir bien
par le sabotage interne ce qui s'est
passé c'est très simple on a travaillé
dans des conditions terribles pour
pouvoir respecter parce qu'on savait que
ce gouvernement actuel va chercher des
petits pots en quelque sorte pour nous
éliminer on a tout fait il s'est trouvé
que dans notre liste nationale il y
avait une dame qui avait moins de cinq
ans moins de 25 ans qui est l'âge l'âge
requis parce que ça lui manquait deux
mois alors il fallait le remplacer
c'était à la vite ils ont pris une dame
qui était déjà dans la liste des
suppléants mais la loi nous permet tout
simplement de rectifier ils ont ils nous
ont refusé cette rectification là et
comme il ne pouvait pas éliminer notre
liste et garder leur lis parce qu'eux
aussi ils n'avaient pas pratiquement
respecter la parité qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont sorti pratiquement au
nouveau droit ce qu'on peut appeler
peut-être le drap macky sall ou le droit
à grenoble en tout cas ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est inédit berne a bloqué à
quatre qui passe avec une liste de
titulaire sans suppléant de 53 personnes
et il ya eu à ce cas lui qui va partir
avec une liste de super sans titulaire
santé de tête de liste on va même leur
demander comment ils vont faire pour que
le l'image de la tête de liste qui est
le président ossements son coût soit sur
le but justement on va en parler vous
dites que mais qui sait elle cherche à
éliminer ses adversaires quel est
l'avenir aujourd'hui l'avenir politique
douce même son corps bah l'avenir
politique de ce maroc où ça se voit
aujourd'hui c'est un des principaux qu'à
ranger du président macky sall de
l'actuel président et son avenir
politique tout le monde le sait ils sont
pas de popularité grimpe encore
rappelons nous qu'en mars 2021 il a tout
fait pour l'empêcher pour l'emprisonner
pour le détruire parce que depuis qu'il
est là il ne fait que détruire ses
opposants et comme il a aujourd'hui un
projet totalitaire c'est à dire rester
au pouvoir avis donc tous nous tous les
moyens sont bons pour éliminer tout
opposant qui se dresse devant lui mais
vous allez voir
de suite ce mercredi 8 juin vous allez
voir que actuelle comme macky sall est
le président le plus impopulaire de
l'histoire politique du sénégal c est
pourquoi on va réussir d'abord le pari
de la mobilisation et tous les leaders
des rues askanwi de l'opposition je
dirais même toutes les forces vives de
la nation vont se retrouver à la place
de lass de la nation et dire que ça
suffit aujourd'hui on ne peut plus à
21e siècle où tous les pays sont en
train de voir comment gérer cette crise
ça passe au niveau de l'ukraine ce qui
se passe
19 lui il est toujours là à chercher
comment freiner ses opposants comment
voler des élections comment pérenniser à
la tête du sénégal alors vous appeler à
la manifestation
on suivra évidemment cette manifestation
avec nos correspondants à dakar et on
écoutera demain qu'est un ministre qui
s'exprimera ou non le ministre de la
pêche voilà qui s'exprimera qui répondra
donc à votre intervention merci beaucoup
el malick ndiaye d'avoir répondu à nos
questions dans le journal de l'afrique
et on termine cette édition par des
sonorités gnaoui cet art musical
d'afrique du nord inscrits de pim 2019
au patrimoine culturel immatériel de
l'unesco et pour cela nous allons à
essaouira au maroc où se tient en ce
moment son célèbre festival de musiques
du monde un événement qui se déplacera
dans plusieurs villes marocaines
reportage de notre correspondant jean
marie lemaire
le festival gnaoua fête ses 25 ans
d'existence et le coup d'envoi est donné
par l'incontournable parade avenant au
coeur de la cité 10 équipes
cette année la première fois le bon aloi
festival tour sera itinérant et se
produira dans quatre villes du royaume a
été obligé un peu partout resserré pour
des raisons sanitaires de de dispatcher
festival ce sera une programmation
différente bien sûr
chaque villa aura sa programmation et
et
c est ces fusions et c'est grave
[Musique]
et ces fusions qui font la renommée du
festival le ravissement des spectateurs
il y en a il y en aura tout plus
envoûtante les unes que les autres
[Musique]
je voyais vraiment tout le monde qu'ils
bougeaient disant que la ville revient
la vie devient parce que la musique
c'est l'avion
[Musique]
tombe sur la cité de mogador et les
concerts se succèdent avec les
rencontres improbables et des artistes
engagés
[Musique]
moi je suis là pour
défendre les femmes en général ça fait
partie de mon de ma carrière ça fait
partie de mon vide ça c'est partout 2
ça pose au travail
ce sont les familles les enfants y est
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
marrakech sera la prochaine étape pour
le cloud festival tour puis après une
halte à casablanca les derniers concerts
auront lieu à rabat la capitale du maroc
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'afrique rester avec nous la faut
continuer sur france 24
[Musique]